Visualizations are more than just data or charts
or maps, at their best they're a story. Humans
really have been telling each other stories
as their primary means of communications
and education for tens of thousands of years.
Whether around a campfire or using modern media,
the fact of the matter is that there's a
lot of power to the phrase once upon a time.
We're wired for stories. And visualization
takes work to create stories out of it,
and some of that work really has
nothing to do with the visualization.
It really is about the storytelling aspect to
it. Just like great design is about strategy and
thinking and planning before the first stroke of
the paintbrush, it's no less so in visualization.
Visualizations, especially interactive ones,
aren't necessarily consumed in a linear way,
like a book. You can't necessarily control how
your user processes the information you give them,
but you can structure a story in a
narrative way with a narrative process.
You could encourage users to walk
through the information in a linear,
progressive way even though
you can't force them to do it.
So, let's look at stories. The fact is that
stories have a very simple structure. Everyone
has a beginning, a middle, and an end. A more
nuanced view includes a few more elements.
The beginning of the story and then the
protagonist faces a serious challenge,
and then there's the middle of the story
and then there's some sort of climax.
Then there's the denouement, that's
sort of like, after the climax,
things start to wrap up all the way down into
the grand finale where the book closes. If you
think about your visualization in these terms
as much as you can, you really can't go wrong.
Here, we're going to design a visualization
together using this structure as our guiding
principle. So, the first thing you do is you
define a headline, and there may be more than one
headline. In fact, it is recommended that you go
through the process of thinking of more than one.
It is as if coming up with a New York Times
headline, which is a very serious and journalistic
and straightforward headline. And then there's the
New York Post version, which is a little bit more
salacious and crazy and scandal-ridden. Sort of
the fun one versus the serious one. And sometimes
for your visualizations, you may lean one way or
the other, but play around with headlines. The
headline is the most important top line summation
of the story you're trying to tell. You can also
think about the headline in terms of, what will
people tweet when they share your visualization.
And you also want to, when you're coming up with
your headline, actually use blank spaces when
you're thinking about it for the data parts.
So, in other words, you want to minimize bias.
Your next point in the hierarchy of your data
visualization is your introduction. In an
infographic like this, it's just a paragraph.
It's establishing the premise and the context
for the visualization before diving into the
data, and it belongs below the headline at the
top of the page to draw the eye there first.
Again, this is conceptual and structural,
using the story as our guiding principle. This
is not meant to be the design. If you think
of it in the story standpoint the headline and
the introduction is the beginning of our story.
Now let's move on to the challenge. There
are a lot of ways to add the “challenge”
to a visualization. One is simply to add a
callout, big, bolded text like this that calls
out the main idea of the story you're trying
to tell or the problem that's being addressed
or the question that your visualization
is meant to answer. In this wire frame,
this bold type will really draw the eye. In a real
graphic, it could take different visual forms.
We've set up the premise, we've gotten the user
into it, now we're going to load them up with
data, and here's where the chart with all the
detail and the interactivity and imagery is
going to go, in this gray area in the middle.
This is where the user is going to spend most
of their time really exploring and playing
around and looking at the data. Next, how do
we introduce the climax, the sort of pivotal
moment in the experience? And we're going to
look at two different scenarios, one is a static
infographic and one is an interactive chart.
In a static infographic, you have information
here, that's really meant to be consumed linearly.
Of course, people are going to start on the
left if they're left-to-right language readers.
They're going to follow the arrows, and more
likely than not, end up on the right-hand side.
But if we had a climax, a big story, a special
thing that we wanted to draw attention to,
we’re going to highlight it, maybe in a visually
interesting way. So, we’re going to create a focal
point that's going to contain the climax. It could
actually contain the conclusion or the challenge.
This might draw the eye there first.
Of course , we might have killed that
linear progression experience because
someone is going to read this first.
But again, the idea isn't necessarily to
enforce linear consumption of the content,
it's just to use that structure
when you're thinking about it.
Now, if we are trying to do this in an interactive
graphic, the approach might be a little bit
different. You can enforce a linear consumption
of the content by having a Next button and making
your users click Next and Next to reveal one
piece of the story after another exactly how
you want to tell it, and then you can do
the big reveal at the end of that process.
So, now we have the exact same visual
structure as the static infographic,
but we're forcing the user to get
to it piece by piece, bit by bit.
Or another way to do it is to have
sorting and filtering buttons.
You might put your filters in a certain order,
and again, assuming people are going to go left
to right, which is a relatively safe assumption,
but not always. You can encourage a user to use
certain filters first, clicking on the left,
and then when they click on that filter,
you might be able to highlight certain things.
When the data reveals, one bar is taller than the
others and you can use a callout to highlight
something interesting that happened there.
Again, the user is progressing through the
content, and there isn't necessarily a denouement.
Sometimes you might not get the opportunity
to conclude things for them because they
couldn’t find the things they
are looking for and just leave.
It's hard, in that situation, to offer conclusions
and to deconstruct things for them sometimes,
but it's a really good exercise to try
to think about how you would do that.
If we go back to our static infographic, it's
really easy to offer a conclusion on the page.
We're used to seeing it in the lower right-hand
corner. You have a box with the small print,
the footer. It's very easy to see structurally.
It is also strongly recommended that you always
include your sources. Where did this data
come from? Why should one believe you?
Why is it valid? It is part of the
conclusion in a story structure.
In an interactive infographic, you can also
offer more conclusion-like things. After your
users go through this deep exploration process,
they're trying to find deeper information and
their own discovery, they can deconstruct the info
themselves, but then at the end, there's a Next
button and they click through and you can sort
of offer them this summed up view of the data.
There are a lot of ways to introduce
conclusions and denouements into interactivity
even though you're never guaranteed
that people will experience them.
It's really helpful to think of every project,
even your non-linear interactive ones,
within that linear storytelling framework. It
helps you work through functionality logic as
well as the hierarchy of information, and
it also helps you measure your success.